o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vermelho mostrado de que o que vai ser
melhor é mais épica mais de sua
estrutura foi inserir aqui do canal que
é fácil leite 34 já sabem pessoal vão
buscar umas cuecas novas aumenta o
volume momento fullscreen no máximo
porque os crimes se no máximo hora lá
buscar a cueca já sabem o volume no
máximo não quero ficar sozinho é preciso
de vocês eu sou um rapazinho dentro de
um quarto meu deus já estou chorar do
que os animais tronics o fox e ética o
boni rio fred ele está aqui alguém na
cama eu não tenho certeza se os teus por
entregue ou não o seu gol em freire não
sair
diga nos comentários que só não sei
muito acerca das finais entre eles
quatro e daqui não sai agora sim bateram
à porta
vocês foi no jogo mas eu acho que o
painel total de bater à porta que se
abriu a porta o morro e eu morrerei
alguém matou através da porta ou demônio
amanhã é um outro dia ok que aconteceu
noite 11 um tabu freire em cima da cama
eu tenho certeza que isso vai ser muito
bom eu tenho esse desapreço luta que
isto vai ser o melhor formato e 34 é que
eu estou eu tenho que jogar aqui
o google está e para onde caiu para
fechar as portas têm que usar um chip é
isso ok flashing lights no controlo não
sair daqui agora ao que me passaram que
o rato ajapi
há uma porta aberta é mister mas
assinala que passei por aqui também
o gol ou tá tudo isso porque o ovo
cuidadosamente antes isto estou ouvindo
uma respiração am fecha a porta
isto não havia uma conspiração usa então
usar flash lite acho que é isso para lá
ao cais é sempre a mesma coisa o shift
para acender a luz não encontrou vacilos
e oxi fechar a porta é isso tem um
enfoque da família que vive nesta casa
o transporta aqui funciona tudo da mesma
maneira né
era isso sendo ok sendo luz e que fecha
a porta ok acho que já estou primeiro
jogo está completamente frente do forno
juntos farinati fredes este 4º passeio
de brinquedos meu isto assusta e isso
assusta para caraças e 12 da manhã já eu
não fiz nada ainda jadson igreja
indicações porque eu já estava fechado e
agora só tem que fazer isso ficar atento
às portas e ao armário eu não sei pra
que se formaram mas deve ser precisa
esconder o óbvio né
mas no trailer no trailer o fox estava
dentro do estado mário por isso tenho de
ter cuidado o quanto estou aqui dentro
não é senão o fox veio por trás e não
sei pra que serve
será que alguém vai entrar dentro do
quarto que tem de fazer é o que é que eu
voltava a lei melhor e trabalhando fecha
a porta à caraças fecha a porta fecha a
porta
em 16 garis se chama por silvio zanello
a minha câmera captar por que por que
alguém entrou dentro do meu quarto -
vamos formalizar que fosse por mário
alguém que entra não devolver essa aqui
eu acho que houve uma descrição ok
ninguém está aqui na outra por tentarem
na outra porta meu ano lá eu acho que
está aqui ouvi um barulho o que é isto
foi um bom começo é vamos lá tentar
outra vez jogará seis garis thuoc bora
lá pessoal segunda tentativa da primeira
noite supostamente eu vivo pedro granja
por isso não vi a ver aqui de nomes mas
há lá eu não estivesse nervoso agora eu
não tomava inspiração nenhuma policiais
que você lê o que é tranquila um relógio
ea frente meu esta casa é uma cabra como
é que vocês metem fotos da vossa fé que
um cara no carro som brado não pode ser
nunca façam isso eu vou seguir hoje eu
vou ficar eu vou ficar aqui porque eu já
estava na outra porta eu acho que está
aqui agora envolve primeiro
tranquilo tranquilo
antes sempre aquela palpitação no
coração que barco vai rolar um susto mas
na altura mário é que eu não sei ainda
pra que serve eu acho que alguém vai
entrar dentro do meu quarto eu preciso
me esconder aqui dentro supostamente é
isso né tá aqui alguém
a lo a carregar sua vida eu o vi notei
que ele estava ok são três da manhã já
estamos a meio da noite e eu vou manter
essa porta fechada porque aceitar que
lixo eu sair eu ouvi lo
eu tenho medo de acender a luz aqui né
na série e nunca cientista em um jogo
ter medo acender a luz não não eu vou
fechar a porta está aqui tá aqui ouviram
eu tô aqui mas não vou bater à porta
fechada eu vou manter a produção da o2
com maiúscula mario em ver as portas
dessa porta quando haverá outra garota
colocou como ele não foi para a porta -
não fui para a porta não sei mas acho
que os meus vizinhos estão os meus
gritos eu acho que os inventários sentir
um feeling do jogo também mas não
interessa o que importa é que eu tenho
que passar esta noite agora ó confronto
mas tem outro lado oposto à volta o
quarto tem q cama com fred e oque eu não
tinha visto isto ainda deve ficar atenta
cama então eu não sei que aqui escrevi
que se tóquio já saí eu já saí eu ficar
de costas pro armário fosse solta dentro
o que quer dizer que tudo o tempo o fox
está lá dentro é isso aí nos comentários
pessoal o que é que isto quer dizer eu
não saí como é que eu vou passar um
pouquinho 8 não sair ninguém aqui está
tudo bem em dar alguma coisa várias
vezes desde o foco e não entrou não ok
eu vou virar sobre se estava livre
até mesmo o técnico
já sei aí eu tenho que matar a gente
vive com luz é isso tem matar os bichos
gaúcha e já tô primeiro jogo
já toquei e pessoal bora lá vão estar
atentos agora as portas tem estado
também tem jackman que você nem pelos oc
é tranquilo vamos lá armário só para
evitar que o foco se o cara tranqüilo
outra porta que os bichos possível na
câmera tem de apontar a luz pessoas
morrerem em si mesmo a cair uma
inspiração faixa que já foi embora ea
fox e fox e eu sei com facilidade duplo
sentido
não houve um estudo de andar em andar no
quarto ou havemann mantém a faca em
porta fechada sem medo acender as luzes
e agora ela já tem medida que a porta
tem fica fechado alguém tentará quebrar
a porta está sentido eu vou sentir
cheirar pousade não nem tira 22 de xerox
mãe eu não sei que aqui é que eu quebrei
de fredes não sei onde meu deus meu deus
existe e está muito intenso a questão
sem tamanho
são cinco da manhã a escola passar a
noite estamos quase a passar a noite lá
andam a dar que pensar isto está
tranqüilo
se não fosse boa boa é conseguir passar
a primeira noite pessoal e saída foi
quem manhã até pessoal agora já estou
percebido já sei como é que fazer as
coisas mas nesta segunda à noite vai
ficar para o próximo episódio que vai
ser hoje vocês apoiarem muitos filhos
por isso deixou a fag favorito e pronto
e vamos jogar a 4 mesmo então é só sabem
é que favorito fique bem até a próxima